elle a écrit une première fois à jour
par m'a tuer omar raddad le jardinier
marocain inculpés dans cette affaire on
s'est contenté d'un soupçon d'un préjugé
et on n'a pas essayé d'avoir le coeur
net
[Musique]
le principal suspect de ce meurtre est
le jardinier mais les voisins mais
fournissent un alibi près sûr que c'est
pas possible ça soit nuit étant donné
qu'il travaillait toute la journée chez
moi ce jour là et que je n'ai pas vu
partir en série l instant
[Musique]
nous déposerons une nouvelle demande de
mise en liberté aux intérêts d'omar
raddad a été tué dans des conditions
horribles le 23 juin elle a écrit une
première fois à genoux omar m'a tuer est
une deuxième fois couchée sur le côté
avant de mourir à marc m'a tuer et avant
cela elle a poussé contre la porte un
lit et une marre de faire pour empêcher
celui qui était sorti et a fermé la
porte en clé de rentrée voilà quelle est
ma position
[Musique]
il ya cent ans condamné un jeune
officier qui avait le tort d'être juifs
aujourd'hui on condamne au jardinier
parce qu'il a le tort maghrébins
[Musique]
s'il est innocent alors que l'innocence
puisse être prouvé devant d'autres
jeunes
obtenez toujours prouver votre innocence
et bien sûr parce que c'est moi je
trouve c'est quelque chose qui paraît
loin d'apporter il faut tous ensemble on
laisse pas la justice à faire des choses
pareilles on s'est contenté d'un soupçon
d'un préjugé et on n'a pas essayé
d'avoir le coeur net
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
qui étaient mélangées au sang de la
victime donc forcément il s'agit de
l'adn du vrai coupable
alors pourquoi on ne veut pas savoir la
vérité pourquoi ne pas avoir été
jusqu'au bout
si véritablement on est en mesure
aujourd'hui avec les techniques que nous
avons aujourd'hui qui n'existait pas il
ya 25 ans la possibilité de pouvoir dire
quelque chose qui nous permet de nous
rapprocher plus de la vérité qui avait
pu le faire la cour d'assises de
l'époque
évidemment que ce sera fait
[Musique]
j'ai déposé une requête en révision
parce que je détiens des éléments
nouveaux
extrêmement importants qui sont des
preuves scientifiques
omar haddad a droit à son deuxième
procès
[Musique]